Speaker 1: We're going to take a quick tour
through sort of a new level of depravity for
radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor.
GREENE And she's as disgusting as she is hypocritical.
Remember all of Marjorie Taylor Greene's my
hip stuff where somebody would ask her, hey,
are you vaccinated?
And she would go, Well, that's my hip.
And of course, it wasn't.
HIPA relates to the transmission of medical
data by medical professionals and providers
and insurance companies and associated organizations.
If a reporter goes, Hey, are you vaccinated?
It doesn't violate HIPA.
But we now have Marjorie Taylor GREENE sharing
the medical information of a child.
Now we're going to look at an article from
LGBTQ Nation.
There's nothing really concerning in what
I'm going to show you.
But there are like sort of very mild medical
pictures that are going to come up as part
of what Marjorie Taylor GREENE tweeted just
as a heads up.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE shares child's medical
photos in bizarre, anti-trans rant.
It's not clear the congresswoman even knows
what the photos show, but she's sure they
show a minor and she shared the pictures anyway.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE shared pictures of
one or more minors on Twitter in order to
attack the family of a possibly transgender
young person.
This child is not old enough to vote, buy
cigarets or watch an R-rated movie, but they
let her choose to have them cut her breast
off, she wrote while sharing a tweet with
two pictures.
One of the pictures shows a girl in her early
teens fully dressed.
The other shows a young person in their late
teens or early twenties shirtless.
After what happens, what appears to be a double
mastectomy.
My Protect Children's Innocence Act will stop
this, she wrote, referring to a bill she introduced
last month.
Green retweeted anti-trans activist Chloe
Cole, who wrote Seattle Reality Check.
Nothing is okay about this.
Okay, so the pictures are here.
Okay.
There's there's really nothing there's almost
nothing that we can see here on the left.
Again, it's a picture of what appears to be
a young woman.
And then on the right, you can't even really
tell if it's the same person.
You can't really tell anything about it.
There's someone with with Band-Aids over their
nipples and there's a scar.
And there could have been a double mastectomy
there.
We don't even really know who this is or what
it is.
But Marjorie Taylor Green's belief is that
it's all the same person and that at least
in some of these pictures, maybe all this
individual is a minor.
Now, what's called gender affirming surgery
is not performed on minors rights, LGBTQ nation.
In fact, the oft repeated claim was rated
false by PolitiFact.
Nevertheless, the idea that children's hospitals
are performing gender affirming surgeries
on young children has gained traction on the
far right, leading to harassment and death
threats against pediatricians.
Okay, I don't even care about that part because
we've covered that part before.
This is not a hippo issue.
What Marjorie Taylor GREENE did here is not
a HIPA issue.
HIPA relates to medical professionals and
related organizations sharing information
about patients.
But if Marjorie Taylor GREENE is concerned
with medical privacy to the point where when
she's asked by a journalist, are you vaccinated?
She goes, That's my HIPA.
You don't get to ask me that.
Then she really should care about this.
This should be wrong based on her own apparent
moral compass.
There is no such thing as a low below which
this woman will not stoop.
She's a horrible person.
I hope that there are consequences for this.
These people offer nothing substantive.
And as we talked about earlier in the show,
when Lauren Boebert, during her debate against
her opponent in Colorado, mentioned Nancy
Pelosi's con job a dozen times.
Part of it is that stuff works to some degree
with their electorate because their electorate
is so weaponized.
The other part of it is they don't actually
have anything substantive to offer.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE doesn't offer any policy,
and this is what you get when you put these
people in power retweeting pictures of individuals
she believes are minors.
We don't know that they're minors.
We don't know the origins of the picture.
We really don't know anything.
But she believes that at least in one of those
pictures, that individual is a minor.
If it's even the same person in both pictures.
And she still is retweeting and amplifying
it, it's absolutely horrifying.